Let me show you three different types of kernels that are used
in doing various types of of H detection.
The Prewitt, the Sobel, and the Roberts.
The Prewitt kernel basically uses negative values in this and
positive values, and of course a transpose.
The Sobel gives it a little bit more heavier thing to the middle kernel.
Our middle values.
Remember we looked at trying to look at points where sometimes just giving it
a ramp in the middle gives a little bit more information locally.
Transpose of this is, of course, here.
The Roberts one is even simpler,
except it actually basically puts in values at the two different end diagonals.
And uses that to compute radiance.
Let's try this on our input image.
I'm just showing you the response for the derivative in x.
You can extrapolate and see what it would look like in y.
You notice that, of course,
it does actually a pretty good job in trying to compute the gradients.
Or the gradient in x, in this instance.
I'm aware that the, perhaps at resolution, you can't see the details.
But hopefully, you'll trust me.
And we'll try to make some of these available to you.
Of course, we're interested in computing edges.
So from this set of input images in Hx,
let's see what we can what edges would look like.
I have yet to explain how we're going to go to edge from here.
But I just wanted to show you examples right now.
This is basically doing edge detection from the original image
using the Prewitt, the Sabel operator, and the Roberts one.